hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast germline cancer genetics in
2015 we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth I'm Judy O'Rourke and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we have
a few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or sharing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button or left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Judy Garber MD
MPH dr. Garber is the director for the
Center for cancer genetics and
prevention susan m smith center for
women's cancers dana-farber Cancer
Institute I will now turn it over to dr.
Garber formal presentation good
afternoon thanks for joining me for this
discussion of germline cancer genetics I
know that a lot of the lectures in this
series are about really the technical
issues in genetics and genomics and
today we're going to talk a little bit
about some of the clinical issues that
are raised by evaluation of germline
genetics and as this slide says since I
change the title slightly many of those
things are intentional of course and
some are more inadvertent I do have some
conflicts of interest to disclose and
those are related to clinical trial work
with agents for patients women with
breast cancer and ovarian cancer related
to brca1 and 2 mutations and so it is
certainly the genomic era and although I
haven't used to slide like this in many
years when Angelina Jolie announced that
she was having prophylactic surgeries
because of a hereditary predisposition
cancer she really did change the face of
cancer genetics in many ways and
internationally there has been an
increase in the number of women pursuing
genetic testing and this has been
sustained since this announcement now
two years ago recently our ovaries were
removed as well most of what is known
about hereditary predisposition or
genetic risk of cancer comes from the
early model work all mathematical by
Alfred knutson and Louise strong and
they identified patterns of cancer and
hypothesized that some individuals were
born with a predisposition to cancer not
cancer itself and that this was because
they carried a mutation in one copy of
pair jeans and they expected these to be
genes involved in regulation not in
structure and time has proven them
correct the first gene cloned that
conferred risk of cancer was RB the gene
for hereditary retinoblastoma and in
rapid succession BRF p53 and a number of
other genes came along and now there are
hundreds of hereditary predisposition
genes and often there are genes that
perhaps you may not have known about or
syndromes that were not so well
recognized tumor suppressor genes are
those which in their normal function
really prevent cancer when one gene is
altered in fact function is generally
normal although there are some dose
effects when the second copy is lost in
an individual cell then there is much
more propensity for DNA damage and
accumulation of error changes in passage
through the cell cycle and much cancer
predisposition presents this way this is
not the only kind of cancer
predisposition there are some genes that
are unka genes inherited in the
so-called on position so you can think
of tumor suppressor genes as and the
brakes and oncogenes as the accelerator
if that's easier this is an example of a
family that might present in which a
hereditary predisposition could be
active the patient with breast cancer
is female and females are always circles
on pedigrees males are squares this is
not my convention if the symbol is
colored in generally that's the disease
of interest I and the arrows indicate
the patient's of interest so the 32 year
old with breast cancer has a family
history on the paternal side with
multiple individuals with breast cancer
including a male with breast cancer and
a woman with very early onset disease
cancers generally occur when they're
solid tumors at least in individuals
late in life 29 is quite young and this
woman also had ovarian cancer on the
mother's side the mother also had breast
cancer but there are multiple female
family members who had no cancer at all
until late ages so one would be more
concerned about the paternal lineage
this is the Where's Waldo cartoon that
many may recognize in the book and Waldo
is a character who appeared on every
page difficult to identify from
everything that looked around him to be
other people once you knew where Waldo
was however although Waldo is whip [ __ ]
see there is I'm then obviously one
could look exactly the same place every
time and there he'd be so impatient
testing one tries to test the individual
in a family with the highest chance of
carrying a predisposing mutation and
once that mutation is identified other
family members can be found to either
share the mutation or not if a mutation
is present and a family member does not
share that mutation then they also do
not share the hereditary risk I'm we
suggest that features of families that
that might indicate that a hereditary
predisposition might be present include
of course multiple cancers and family
members this can be challenging for
diseases like breast or colon cancer
which are common in the population so
having multiple affected family members
is not rare I you can use age then to
help decide to family members with
breast cancer in their 70s certainly
don't confer the same risk as two family
members with breast cancer in their 20s
and 30s multiple primaries suggesting
increased susceptibility to cancer
sometimes by laterality of tumors
multiple renal cell carcinomas for
example some tumors are more often
bilateral like ovarian cancer there are
multiple in these described syndromes
you can see constellations of tumors
together so breast and ovarian cancer in
the hereditary breast ovarian cancer
syndromes or colon and uterine cancers
in Lynch syndrome for example you look
for multiple generations if the families
are small you may not see them and there
may be associated findings such as
congenital anomalies or sometimes
specific tumor histologies many patients
have been tested in the past and were
negative but you might have reason to
retest those patients and these would be
for example if you always wondered
whether there was a mutation because of
family history or that new family
members are affected or the patient
herself or himself develops a second or
third malignancy if genetic testing
changes so we've been hearing two in
your other lectures about
next-generation sequencing by and large
I imagine and other technologies that
have been able to look at large numbers
of genes more frequently or more easily
and that has certainly changed the way
testing has been offered in these
settings and I'll talk about that some
more there are clinical guidelines about
who might be tested and these have
changed over time and then as I'm sure
you've heard if you're studying tumors
so you're looking now at two genomes the
somatic genome of the tumor that's
acquired a number of mutations and the
original genome of the individual the
patient perhaps who was born with
certain mutations if you study only the
tumor you may not be able to tell
whether some of the mutations identified
originated in the patient or the tumor
and we'll discuss this some more so
let's talk for example about a condition
that we know a lot about because that is
changing as testing becomes more widely
available and more comprehensive so
we've had 20 years to study the brca1
and brca2 hereditary breast ovarian
cancer predisposition genes and you can
see that already the names are not
completely
helpful because they sound like breast
cancer genes and they are associated
with the highest risks of breast cancer
in brca1 or 2 but also with ovarian
cancer more in brca1 with a small but
real risk of male breast cancer very
small but certainly real risk of
pancreatic cancer and increasingly data
that there is a form of prostate cancer
that is more common in BRCA carriers and
this would be a more aggressive form of
prostate cancer so well there is not
necessarily an earlier age at diagnosis
the tumors themselves are more
aggressive and are more likely to ask
you to appear across the age spectrum
whoops nothing's happening I think we're
frozen but I'll try again so my slide
will not advance let's see what happens
if there's another way to do this um so
my slide is not moving so if I'm going
to disappear for one second and just see
if it's the connection to my my house
hold on so I'm sorry I advance the slide
Judy or done do you have a way to help
with this well I can talk to you through
his lights because I can see them but I
don't think you can see them I'm why
don't we just keep going and hopefully
they'll find a way to fix what's
happening here I'm hoping you can still
hear me
and so well so I just wanted to mention
that there have been guidelines for the
management of patients with these risks
of cancer that have come because of all
the work that's gone on before now
recently there's been a paper from Tim
rebeck and colleagues using data from
the simba consortium so one of the ways
that my whole screen is frozen whoops
there we go you know thank you okay
thank you Judy so I can't move the slide
still well I'm not sure what to do but I
guess they're take it under control so
in any case and there is evidence of
genotype-phenotype correlation this
means of course that mutations oh I'd
say
well hopefully this won't be working
better now yes look at that okay
hopefully we're back on so
genotype-phenotype correlation well
there are tens of thousands of
individuals with identified mutations in
brca1 and brca2 and Tim rebek took these
data from this large consortium to which
most active researchers around the world
have contributed and has identified as
you can see some variation in risk
associated with specific location of
mutations in brca1 and 2 and the
question is whether this will be as
something that has clinical utility and
the expectation is that it will in
addition there are modifier genes so by
studying individuals with the same
mutations who developed cancers at
different times of life one can look and
see whether mutations in other genes
such as hormone metabolizing jeans or
carcinogen metabolizing jeans or snips
at the locations of unclear function
might affect breast cancer or ovarian
cancer risk and they do these two are
easily tested for and could be used for
clinical purposes and there's so much
data available now that you really can
for example demonstrate that MRIs add to
the two screening for early cancers and
are better than mammograms even in women
as they get older and their breasts
should get easier to image and that
prophylactic surgery is effective at
reducing the incidence of breast cancer
for sure and that the surgery itself can
have good cosmetic result so that women
can find the option more accessible
acceptable and the very powerful data
that removal of the ovaries and
fallopian tubes really almost eliminates
the risk of ovarian and related cancers
now not completely because there are
still related tissues in the area but
this is helpful since there's no good
early detection for ovarian cancer and
you can see that more than reducing the
incidence of cancer using genetic
information of this power can help to
reduce mortality as well so
people who have their ovaries removed
are more like are less likely to die not
only from ovarian cancer but also from
breast cancer and data from the group
here at the Brigham has identified early
precursor cells in the fallopian tubes
themselves suggesting that ovarian
cancer does not necessarily develop in
the ovaries but actually in the
fallopian tubes next door so there are a
lot of ways to do studies like this if
you are interested in the genomics of
all of this the most important issue is
that you have the appropriate specimens
to work from and some of these
conditions are quite rare so for example
in the era of targeting EGFR mutant lung
cancers with agents that can exploit
this weakness on the specific mutation
t790m is a common mechanism by which
these lung cancers develop resistance to
the EGFR inhibitors but there is a small
group of patients who have a t790m
mutation before ever receiving the
targeted therapy they're about half of
those patients can be shown to have a
germline or inherent mutation in t 79 in
in egfr at t790m and those patients
appear to have familial lung cancer risk
so here's a pedigree with multiple lung
cancers three in one generation and the
mother and the maternal grandfather on
and his brother and the mutation can be
identified not only in the tumor but
also in the germline and now you can use
the internet to collect families and
where individuals have this mutation
because they know that they do on this
issue of studying the tumor to get
access to the germline is perhaps a
little reverse from what we had expected
but certainly germline genetic
information is helpful now for many
tumor analyses looking for acquired
mutations to target with therapy it is
helpful to know the germline so that you
can subtract out mutations that have
been present inherently in the
individual and are not acquired by the
tumor and
for not good therapeutic targets to
geneticists this is sort of a waste
because you're throwing away all that
you've learned about the germ line from
that part of the analysis here for
example is a paper from le van alen in
the group here as part of the ESCA stand
up to cancer project where prostate
cancers were sequenced looking for
targets in hormone resistant tumors and
you can see that in the group with the
standard genomic profile with p10
mutations which are known to be common
and pik3ca mutations that targeting the
mtor pathway with pi3 kinase in a cane
akt inhibitors can be quite effective
but within this project they identified
a patient with a brca2 mutation in his
tumor and when we tested his blood he
did have a germline mutation in brca2 so
instead of targeting his p10 system his
therapy targeted of the brca2 deficiency
with investigational drugs like parp
inhibitors and approved drugs like
platinum most recently bell kill SQ from
hopkins looked at this issue of
screening tumors just by looking at the
tumor DNA and not sequencing the
germline if you go on and use the
various databases to try to assign
significance to all of the sequence
variants that are found in the genes
that you choose to examine so you
usually have to scream through and
eliminate genes that are two common
because you will be spending years
curating the data set but if you can
look at those that are for example less
than 1% and try to subtract out what you
assume to be germline mutations just
using databases you will have a very
high rate of miss classification and if
here's just using the cosmic database
you can get a sense for the amount of
error that can be made by
misunderstanding here at dana-farber
where we have an existing program called
profile that's used for these and for
tumor sequencing this is an a study that
looks at approximately 300 genes known
to be important in cancer and cancer
position though we don't routinely do
the germline yet we do a lot of curation
that accounts for possible germline
influence and this kind of more
thoughtful curation can help us to avoid
at least some of the problems that one
would otherwise encounter but here for
example is patient this young woman here
who had a thyroid cancer at 21 which was
analyzed by in the profile project by
the aqua panel technology and had a beer
annotation identified which is quite
commonly acquired in thyroid cancer and
was not remarkable and had an ATM
variant that was is also quite common in
the general population so not
necessarily part of this syndrome but
had a brca2 alteration identified in
thirty eight percent of reeds and not
fifty percent but still high enough that
when she had germline sequencing she was
found to have a brca2 mutation now that
mutation would have been expected to
have existed in a family with a history
of breast and ovarian cancers but as you
can see she has quite a small family and
a lot of males on her father's side not
much on her mother's side and an
unaffected mother there is a breast
cancer back here there's another thyroid
cancer that's not usually part of the
syndrome so we have not yet figured out
exactly what this means we certainly
would not have tested her based on this
information but now we know from her
tumor sequence that going further she
has a germline brca mutation um however
most physicians are more comfortable
focusing just on the somatic mutations
of the tumor and looking at targeted
therapies and are not so interested or
comfortable thinking about the germline
implications these are data from Stacey
gray i'm here at dana-farber surveying
on colleges here in the harvard system
who nonetheless were much more
comfortable with somatic than germline
mutations and there is a lot of work
going on for those of you in the
research community asking if you look at
the germline as well as the tumor or if
you're not in cancer and you're looking
at the germline are you ethically
obligated to
turn all the results that you find I'm
and that really depends on the very
specifics of the consent form that your
research subjects I should sign because
generally the feeling is that you are
not obligated to return information
about incidental findings so things you
aren't looking for if this is a study of
mutations looking for contributions to
ALS then you don't have to talk about
genes that predispose to hypertension
but you have to be very clear in what
you agree with or contract with the
patient initially before the specimen is
collected and the analysis begun so that
you are both clear about what you will
and will not disclose their our whole
group studying issues like this in the
American College of medical genetics and
elsewhere so I wanted to talk for a few
minutes about a project that's ongoing
at dana-farber as part of the Caesar
group this is funded by the national
institutes of the National Human Genome
Research Institute and here at
dana-farber this project is actually led
by Levi Garraway and paciotti but I have
been active as well this is a study oh
no we're back I'm if you can advance the
slide and this is a study of patients
with next patients with colon and lung
cancers I don't think these slides do
this all the time but you never know
anyway colon and lung cancers and who
are offered the opportunity to have
their tumor sequenced this is sequencing
in the whole exome and also the exome of
their blood for germline material the
goal is for them to have full sequence
of tumor and your online materials so
that the germline can be subtracted out
but also that they have the option of
learning results of both tumor in germ
line or they can opt out of one or the
other I mean in general if you don't
want your tumor sequence you wouldn't be
in this project could you try again
please to advance the slide
okay well so what the next slide shows
foots and in the first hundred and
thirteen patients there were numerous
mutations perhaps five identified /
tumor on and the vast majority of these
were returned to the patient's physician
for use in trying to identify targeted
therapies it could be used in a
management of these patients with
advanced lung and colon cancer on the
germline side there were also hundreds
of mutations or sequence alterations
identified but only a few percent were
returned to the patient's physician I
mean that's because most of the findings
were not in jeans where they would have
clinical significance I'm but of course
most of the significance is not for the
patient himself that's their or herself
since their usual problem now is
advanced cancer I'm rather than the risk
of other unrelated diseases but there is
implication for family members and this
is why people might consider germline
genetic testing if we did have a patient
who actually had an an actionable
germline mutation in a very important
cancer predisposition gene but that
patient had declined in advance to
receive the results of his genetic
analysis in his germline and therefore
we were unable to disclose that
information to him or to his relatives
I'm so I don't know whether you can do
anything about the frozen screen well
I'm so we'll try to go on here I have
sliced it show some of this more
graphically so that you can see the
kinds of genes that were identified in
the screening but you're just going to
have to take my word for it cuz I can't
make any of these slides come up
don't know if anyone else can up Judy's
gonna try again let's hope for the best
okay let's see well that's something but
now I can't see the rest of the slides
maybe they're coming back let's give it
a minute here I apologize for this um
okay now they're back they're back
you're not moving well this is actually
a test of me to see if I can actually
still give a talk without having the
slides in front of me I'm that will see
if that works art well so for those of
you who are visual I apologized on but
I'm to 33 34 37 can we maybe it's just
slow I don't know well so i'm going to
talk now about genetic testing that is
not available only in the research
setting but also available in the hung
in the clinical setting as part of
commercial testing and this would be
slide 37 judy if you can get it back on
and so about three years ago now perhaps
maryclaire King at the University of
Washington looked at a group of three
hundred sixty patients with unselected
ovarian cancer and by that I mean
patients with ovarian cancer but not
selected for family history in
particular and these patients thank you
these patients and as you can see ad
mutations not only in brca1 and brca2
but also a few mutations in each of 12
other genes so a quarter of the cohort
altogether was found to have a
predisposing mutation potentially now
these the scary part of this from the
clinical perspective was that thirty
percent of the women with mutations did
not have family history and almost forty
percent were older than 60 at diagnosis
in as
told you initially most hereditary
predisposition is present in individuals
diagnosed at unusually young ages so if
we could advance the slide I can tell
you that or next there you go that the
patients that the other genes were genes
that were part of DNA repair pathways
that had been identified once the
function of brca1 and brca2 were clearer
so that these genes which are similarly
important in repair of DNA errors were
looked at and many of them found to be
associated with breast cancer in
families when mutations were present in
the germline this came along at the same
time next slide please in as the ruling
by the Supreme Court that a single
company could not own the patent to
genes and could not own the genes or
have a monopoly on germline testing next
slide please and that led to the
development by many companies now
entering the space of technology for
testing multiple genes in the same assay
so this is not really meant to be read
but this is an analysis or a list of
five products or six I guess we're
next-generation sequencing is used to
analyze the germline for a larger and
larger and ever enlarging group of genes
so until this time testing was limited
to brca1 and brca2 in the breast cancer
arena to about five genes for Lynch
syndrome in the colon cancer families
and a few other genes not much
commercial testing took place for some
of the rarer syndromes but with the move
to next generation sequencing and the
end of the testing monopoly perhaps it
became possible for the same price to
test for an ever-growing number of genes
next slide these genes tend to pre to be
grouped let's say so the numbers are
totally arbitrary but the breast cancer
genes include genes you may be familiar
with if you're at all interested in
cancer biology James
p53 or more recently pal be to mismatch
repair genes for colon cancer polyposis
jeans now and with the addition of the
pole genes and several others so we've
gone from panels of the 14 genes two
panels now up to almost 50 genes with
expectations for getting to 97 genes in
a panel offered in the UK this is very
efficient testing not that you're
looking at all of the other genes in
which you are not interested so forgive
the double negative but these are cancer
related genes but you can look at a
large number of them for a much more
reasonable cost next slide please I the
challenge of this has become partly
definition so when we have previously
discussed syndromes were you generally
talking about clinical syndromes where a
group of cancers might be seen in the
same individual or perhaps the same
family may be at young ages the features
that I gave you before now we may find
an individual with a family history
that's not nearly as compelling but who
madhuram in whom a germline mutation is
found nonetheless and the question is
whether the cancer risks are the same
for two individuals with the same
mutation one with and one without a
family history or does the definition of
a syndrome now require or depend
entirely on the presence of a mutation
or is clinical information still useful
next slide please so we did a small
study with Nadine tongue at Beth Israel
showing that the addition of what we're
calling panel testing these expanded
panels of genes rather than individual
candidate genes has led to an increased
frequency of detection of mutations next
slide please but one example of the the
conundrum that I just described is here
a very classic family with what is
called the leaf immunity syndrome and he
you can see the individual with breast
cancer at a young age with a sibling
with multiple primary tumors these are
rare tumor types adrenocortical
carcinoma osteosarcoma soft tissue
sarcoma by 26 having had three cancers
this is rare here's a lung cancer but at
48 so this is a classic family and most
people would recognize this as
li-fraumeni syndrome genetic test or not
next slide please but in this family and
there is an individual next line tested
I'm at age 48 after being diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer in this individuals
family there are other gastrointestinal
cancers another pancreatic cancer
another GI cancer and a brain tumor all
of which could be the Lynch syndrome and
this individual was tested in the panel
as an efficient way to look at the
multiple genes that predispose to lynch
syndrome and no mutation was found but a
mutation was identified in p53 the rest
of the family so the father was tested
he also was negative for Lynch syndrome
and negative for p53 so this either is
coming from the maternal lineage and we
know nothing about her side of the
family or this is a new mutation in this
patient but we generally would not have
tested him previously for p53 mutation
based on this diagnosis so we're clearly
we're missing some of these and the
definition of li-fraumeni syndrome now
is it that terrible history I showed you
on the previous slide or is having a p53
mutation enough and this comes up now
because healthy individuals are being
tested on these panels and unexpected
mutations are being identified next
slide please this matters for things
like p53 where there are data that
individuals with the mutation and a very
high lifetime risk of breast cancer I'm
sorry of cancer overall multiple cancers
as you can see may benefit from having
screening with a whole-body MRI this is
not a technique that's available
everywhere it's still largely a research
technique it does not include radiation
it does not include contrast so that
makes it
easier to do and we haven't yet proved
that it worked but at least we have
something to offer individuals that is
research to at least find their cancers
early though we can't prevent them at
this time next slide please one problem
as you would anticipate in looking at
the germline of individuals if you're
doing next if you're doing whole exome
or even large numbers of known genes is
the the frequency of unspecified
variants or alterations whose
pathogenicity can really not be
definitively determined using all of the
available data databases and even
functional data at this time and the
more you look the more you find so this
is just a frequency count from 198
patients at Stanford who had their
analysis done and there were certainly
more variance than there were individual
mutations this is fine but you really
can't tell people what they mean and of
course they will be present in family
members because they're sharing DNA next
slide please and these are just our data
from a recent count this is the last six
months of genetic testing being
conducted at dana-farber I'm you can see
that we have moved from focus testing to
panel testing very frequently and
although we have certainly found
mutations I'm in about ten percent of
individuals we've tested we have at
least twice as many variants of
uncertain significance to go with those
findings so people are not always very
happy for having spent the money on the
test next slide please how insurance
does cover this by the way there is a
new project called prompt this is
another example of trying to use the
internet to accelerate research so this
kind of testing is available clinically
and commercially all over the country
and that means that primary care
physicians and gastrin gynecologist can
order genetic testing on their patients
only a blood test after all but when
these uninterpretable results appear
we're asking patients to consider
registering in this online database to
provide their information and perhaps
accelerate the pace
of discovery and risk assessment in
associated with these genes so we want
to establish penetrance for example and
we'll need large numbers of individuals
with mutations that are indeed quite
rare in the population next slide please
I'm so there are risks and benefits or
benefits and limitations of genetic
testing as we've talked about they're
efficient they're less expensive you can
look at multiple genes at the same time
sometimes however you find things that
don't seem to explain the family history
in front of you and you're not always
sure what to do with that information
next slide and you can have this
particular problem where you do this
kind of next-generation approach and
what you find in an unsuspecting
individual are three germline mutations
this may be the record one in brca2 that
perhaps could link to this maternal aunt
with a great-aunt with ovarian cancer
one in pms to which is a colon cancer or
Lynch syndrome gene that might account
for this endometrial cancer although we
can't see much else to go with it up
there and you [ __ ] H was a common gene
and polyposis so this person certainly
did not expect all of this and we now
have to go back through the family find
out how prevalent or what the
distribution of these mutations is since
we don't know whether they're all came
from one side or some from each side or
both sides and that this information
then can be shared with the relevant
family members next slide so I wanted to
shift gears here and talk about another
application of genetic information in
cancer patients this is not really so
much based on on the kind of genomics
that we've talked about but just some of
the recent data that genetic information
can determine the behavior of tumors
that develop in mutation carriers and
therefore can affect treatment decisions
this has led to a lot of pressure for
rapid turnaround of genetic tests and so
in the past if you would recognize that
someone might be a carrier at diagnosis
they could have their adjuvant
chemotherapy and all of their other
management before their final surgery
and the
sults would come back in six or eight
weeks and that would be enough but now
you really want those results back in
two weeks or faster so this is a small
discussion about breast cancers and
individuals with brca1 or 2 mutations
and of course for most of them at
diagnosis the mace the valuable
potential use of the information might
be in choosing to have mastectomy is
instead of more conservative surgery
this to avoid the risk of additional
primary cancers not so much as a
difference in managing the new cancer
and this issue of when to take out the
ovaries since some tumors are hormone
driven removing the ovaries especially
in premenopausal women can affect not
only the risk of new ovarian cancer but
can also be therapeutic for managing the
breast cancer itself not much change for
radiation or her to targeting tumors
next slide please
well there you go so it is surprising I
think still that if you do molecular
analysis these are of breast cancer
subtypes looking at arrays on gene
arrays and that you can see that for
brca1 related tumors the majority
seventy percent do not express either
estrogen or progesterone receptor or her
two and most breast cancers are
characterized for all of these but brca2
related tumors seventy percent of the
time expressed both estrogen and
progesterone receptor but not her too
and the p53 tumors these are the leaf
rimini tumors that I presented to you
before they are generally either
estrogen receptor positive or her2
positive two-thirds of the time and it's
puzzling I suppose in part as well
because the brca1 related tumors almost
always have a p53 mutation in the tumor
although the germline mutation is brca1
so here these tumors have a p53 mutation
but they are a completely different
subtype and whether these arise from
different precursor cells or there's
something else about them that changes
their differentiation along the way is
completely unknown at this time at least
as far as I know next slide please so we
said before that brca1 and 2 are genes
that are important in DNA repair and
they have a specific role in the repair
of homologous recombination in that
pathway in their care of double-strand
breaks in the DNA although they have
roles in multiple functions in the five
DNA repair pathways and here's some data
from David's damn silver and David
Livingstone here at dana-farber showing
that in a brca1 deficient cell that's
been radiated as you might expect if
there's double strand break in the DNA
that when the chromosomes RIA Neil that
you can have some unusual forms and here
is the same unusual form found in a
tumor from an individual with completely
normal brca1 in their germline but in
the tumor the same evidence of DNA
damage is present so proud
a different mutation is present in this
tumor at least maybe in the germline as
well next slide so our group was
interested in whether there were
therapeutic implications for this and we
had the following model that individuals
with d'art brca1 or 2 mutation would
have breast cancers that were of the
triple negative type and with defects of
DNA repair but that there might be a
subset of other breast cancers that were
intact for brca1 but somewhere down the
pathway had similar DNA repair
deficiencies and might benefit from the
same strategies exploiting those
weaknesses next slide there was also
cell line data this is the first brca1
minus minus tumor cell line compared to
tumor cells with intact BRCA genes and
they showed much better killing with the
drug cisplatin which is a DNA
cross-linking agent thought to cause
double strand breaks in the DNA as
compared to doxorubicin which is a I
mean these are drugs that are amused
much more often in the treatment of
breast cancer to which the BRCA tumor
cells were resistant but the other tumor
cells more sensitive next slide please
and we had some data from ovarian cancer
treatment that women with mutations in
brca1 and 2 who God ovarian cancer
actually did a little better than
non-carriers it's not a lot better but
it is better statistically significantly
and the question was was it because
their tumors were more sensitive to the
effect of platinum which is a standard
agent in the treatment of ovarian cancer
next slide so we designed a small trial
this is a neoadjuvant trial for those of
you in research the advantage of
neoadjuvant studies is the patient is
diagnosed they receive their systemic
therapy before surgery so the tumor is
still in place if the tumor shrinks or
disappears completely then the
chemotherapy was likely the right stuff
and was effective and then the patient
goes to surgery you can collect tumor
before surgery and you can collect
persistent tumor at surgery so you can
have a lot of specimens to work with and
we did a small try
of 28 patients with triple negative
breast cancer unselected for their BRCA
status we found that ten percent off six
had their tumors disappear completely 10
had very good clinical responses those
younger women did and both of the women
in the cohort who turned out to have
mutations had their disease disappear as
well and this is what you would have
expected if our hypothesis was correct
that these were the tumors that would
respond to platinum next slide please
Steven a-rod used the same protocol of
platinum to treat women with brca1
mutations these were treated in Poland
where there is a common founder mutation
in the population so an easy and
inexpensive single site genetic test on
these women at diagnosis and sixty
percent or 61 percent of those women had
their tumor disappear completely with
four doses of single-agent ow cisplatin
next slide please so this has led to
some increased activity in the
therapeutic world looking at the value
of cisplatin which is actually
carboplatin but these are old platinum
drugs from long ago now asking do they
have a role in breast cancer treatment
that we might have missed the first time
around and these are data showing that
the addition of carboplatin and this is
the German version increased the
response rate from 38 to fifty-eight
percent which is quite a statistically
significant improvement and the same in
the American version of this trial where
the comparison was against chemotherapy
without platinum and without the
addition of a drug targeting
angiogenesis next slide and the recent
German data showed that in the 315
patients or 295 of them who had triple
negative breast cancer so-called and
could be looked at for their BRCA status
that much of the benefit much greater an
eighty-three percent response rate in
women with carboplatin compared to those
with who did not receive carboplatin and
not nearly the same difference although
a difference in women with family
history and much less difference in
those without a germline mutation at all
next slide
and a new trial presented in December by
dr. tut from the UK in which women with
metastatic triple negative breast cancer
were given either carboplatin or a
taxane the other active drug and they
did cross over a progression if they
wanted to next slide and this slide this
study showed you can advance again that
really most of the benefit of platinum
was in individuals with a germline
mutation not in those without and that
in the group that did not have a
germline mutation platinum might have
been perhaps a little less active
although not statistically significantly
so on than the taxane but the big
advantage here to those with a mutation
at diagnosis next slide but there are
old data to suggest that these tumors
that are based after all on DNA repair
deficiency might be sensitive to other
forms of chemotherapy and it may not be
the platinum at all so these are old
data from Israel where there are also
founder mutations where in this case
fixed tissue platinum I'm sorry
paraffin-embedded tumor tissue from a
cohort now about 25 years old I'm were
looked at with single site testing for
the three founder mutations and the
group divided into those with and
without mutations sorry I'm and those
with mutations did just as well as those
without as long as the brca1 patients
had chemotherapy this was old-fashioned
chemotherapy not platinum not
anthracyclines not taxanes and they did
just as well next slide and data from
the MD Anderson group showing that those
with mutation did better in their
studies of individuals treated with
taxanes and anthracyclines the standard
drugs but not with platinum so they did
well in that case in addition next slide
please I promise we're almost done so we
have a small trial here and at multiple
sites around the country looking at
comparing patients with mutations and
triple negative or high-grade your
positive disease at diagnosis
randomizing them
to platinum or the standard of care and
we'll see whether these tumors really
are more sensitive or just more
sensitive to chemotherapy in general
next slide please I'm next slide please
so the parp inhibitors have been
developed I guess you'll have to hit it
again to look at an exploitation of a
part of the DNA repair machinery not
just the double strand breaks that
platinum does par is an enzyme important
in DNA repair and the inhibitors bind
par to the DNA and make it difficult for
the machinery to progress and repair the
errors if they convert basically single
site defects into double strand breaks
these are data just showing that one of
these elaborate on was effective in
individuals with mutations at the time
they were first treated for metastatic
disease I'm sorry treated for metastatic
disease even though they had received a
number of other agents oh you should get
the sense from this cat scan that
there's a mass here and that that mass
is smaller in the second screen and the
same here where there's a large mass
that didn't belong and that is absent
here and these are just the response
rates next slide please and other data
here again this in a trial for
individuals who had BRCA mutation so the
first time that having a germline
mutation determined eligibility for
treatment these individuals had lung
metastases ease that really almost
disappeared and these are the number of
people responding to therapy next slide
please I'm and they're the data here
showing activity and ovarian cancer at
two different doses next slide please
these are a mutation carriers and here
showing that while in ovarian cancer
these drugs work both in tumors from
people with germline mutations and
without germline mutation so shot some
more common shared mechanism in breast
cancer it's really only people with
mutations who respond to these agents
next slide we're almost done so there
are at least five drugs in this class
that are in development at this time
next slide
one of the obvious trial designs was for
single agent parp inhibitor to be
compared against any of a number of
standard drugs that can be given as the
first line treatment so at first
metastatic disease so unfortunately now
there are three competing trials each
with a similar parp inhibitor in a
two-to-one randomization against the
drug of choice and we hope that at least
one of these will actually complete
enrollment so we will be able to answer
this very important question next slide
please and there is the first of these
I'm sorry you can skip this well you can
leave the slide because it really shows
that these drugs are being tried not
only in breast and ovarian cancer but
also in pancreatic cancer there are
trials and prostate cancer the tumors
that can occur in individuals with a
germline mutation so it suggests that in
some of these individuals with family
history at least or perhaps with
specific histologies that we will be
testing for germline mutation to try to
expand the therapeutic window for these
people with tumors that often respond to
little next slide please this is an
adjuvant trial so drugs that work in
metastatic disease are often moved
earlier in treatment so now this is the
first Park inhibitor study for women who
have completed who have triple negative
breast cancer a germline mutation in
brca1 or 2 who have completed all of
their other therapy either chemotherapy
before surgery or after surgery surgery
radiation whatever and then are
randomized to one year of either the
parp inhibitor or a placebo seeing
whether one can delay recurrence or
prevent recurrence entirely with the use
of these drugs in this setting next
slide this is a large international
effort because it will take 1300 women
to do the study and this trial is up and
running next slide please oh we can skip
these next slide I'm just that you can
combine these drugs with other
chemotherapeutic agents and increase the
response rates next slide please I'm
sorry too much chemo I think I'm an
interesting mechanism of resistance for
those of you in the targeted therapy
arena where
resistance is the problem and here in
BRCA carriers it is possible for a
mutation to be acquired in the existing
germline mutant copy that restores the
protein almost completely and therefore
restores function of the gene brca1 or 2
whichever and this mechanism then the M
sorry these tumor cells that have
reacquired a germline I'm sorry tumor
cells have reacquired a functioning
brca1 or 2 protein can then become
resistant to Platinum's and parp
inhibitors this has been shown in
ovarian cancer and breast cancer largely
by the seattle group and accounts for
about twenty or thirty percent of
resistance to these agents next slide
but there are data that some of these
tumors remain sensitive to Platinum's
even after Park inhibitors and the
mechanism of this is not clear but there
are many mechanisms of resistance so
we'll see next slide on these are just
other combinations that are in trials
next slide I promise we'll get back to
genetics in just a minute you can skip
this next slide and cdk1 inhibitors next
slide and you can even make tumor cells
like lung cancers that were never
sensitive Department hibbett errs
possibly sensitive at this time by
inducing errors with the cdk1 inhibitor
next line I'm and there are efforts of
course to predict sensitivity to these
agents platinum and parp inhibitor by
looking for various defects looking at
the tumor not at the germline since some
of the tumors with acquired mutations in
brca1 or 2 for example can be sensitive
to kills killing by these agents this is
from our little study showing that the
tumors with either germline or acquired
tumor mutations or methylation of brca1
would be sensitive to the BRCA I'm sorry
to intensive to the to the platinum
drugs next slide and this is work from
andrew richardson looking at using on
the predicted telomeric
changes that one would expect if you
have double strand breaks in the DNA
when chromosomes are E&E laughter these
errors they might not be in the proper
orientation and if you just count up the
amount of telomeric error that can be a
score of how well these cells do and
don't repair their DNA errors this was
called none and non allylic till a mirac
imbalance NTA I and this is part of a
tissue based assay that's now being
studied to see whether it predicts
response next slide in our data
presented at the ACR meeting recently it
did predict for platinum response but
there are other datasets in which this
as part of the hrd assay being studied
by myriad genetics did not predict
responders this was true in the TNT
trial that I talked about earlier next
slide I promise we're almost at the end
right so back to genetics so genetic
testing has risks and benefits I'm and
it's important for people generally to
have thought about those before they
have genetic testing there is
direct-to-consumer genetic testing
available at this time there's a company
that does snip analysis but that
includes founder mutations in brca1 and
2 on and that information can be made
available to people without having to go
through their physicians there's a new
panel testing company doing
next-generation sequencing originally at
this point for 17 genes but i'm sure
with plans to expand these include brca1
and 2 and jeans for other strong
predisposition syndromes like lynch
syndrome and for 249 dollars you don't
need a doctor you can call them up and
order your test and they'll have a
physician to it for you this is color
genomics for those of you interested in
checking them out next slide and we
talked about this patient already next
slide you do have to be prepared for the
fact you may find things you wish you
hadn't I'm and then there are a lot of
people who worked on some of the
projects I project I I presented today
and these are the genomic projects with
the help of the Broad Institute next
slide and the triple negative projects
with the help of this group of
individuals at Mass General Dana Farber
Beth Israel
I'm in Spain next slide and for most
patients in the end it comes down to
this to try to understand the risks and
benefits of genetic information the
possibility of erroneous information
which definitely happens and how this
information can be used for their health
thank you for paying attention and for
making it through all of those little
technical errors and I hope you learned
something this afternoon that was of
interest okay there are questions oh
goodness ok so I'm reading these are the
p53 mutations in the brca1 cases loss of
heterozygosity or point mutations so the
p53 mutations that are seen in the
tumors of brca1 carriers are acquired
mutations and they run the gamut as far
as I'm aware from point mutations to
large deletions and p53 as a gene has a
number of types of mutations the
difference between leaf Almunia
mutations are not always the same type
of mutations as somatic mutations well
you know there can be germline mutations
that are that run the gamut as well from
point mutations to rearrangements and
deletions and I guess one is more
confident of deletion mutations as being
functionally significant it is a problem
in p53 that many of the mutations are
missense mutations in the germline as
they are in tumors and therefore
sometimes figuring out the functional
significance or using bioinformatics to
fill out figure out the significance
leaves you with the inability to
determine for sure whether some of these
missense alterations are clinically
significant or not people use the tumor
data absolutely as much as the germline
to try to assign significance it's the
advantage of cancer I guess compared to
diseases that have only one germline to
work with so I think there's no straight
answer to this and there are the usual
efforts with large
databases and consort and assign
significance to mutations both in the
germline and in the somatic space is
there a difference in the response to
parp inhibitors if tumors have certain
p53 mutations in part the question since
individuals so this is a question about
p53 and telomerase so as far as I am
aware PARP inhibitors have not been
shown to be particularly effective in
individuals with leaf a meany or
germline tp53 related tumors although I
am actually not aware to what extent
they've been looked at one would not
expect them to be particularly effective
in that group but that's I really don't
know that for sure telomerase is a very
interesting fact feature of many of
these and other tumors and I'm not sure
that its role in predicting response to
p53 has been looked at its role in
looking at cancer susceptibility to
various things has certainly been looked
at and very intriguing data and its role
in interactions with p53 probably among
the most intriguing data but I don't
think any of those things have yet been
linked to parp inhibition that doesn't
mean they won't be maybe you'll do it
Howard telomeric errors being measured
so telomere errors are really not part
of this kind of germ line I'm discussion
there are many groups looking at
telomerase and telomeric errors scoring
these using genomic technologies that
probably the group furthest along is
that the National Cancer Institute I'm
Steve chanock and Sharon Savage but i'm
afraid that i am not sufficiently
conversant with their approaches to tell
you i'm naturally an Elizabeth oh my god
I'm the Nobel Prize winner who
identified telomerase also has done a
huge amount of work in this area I'm
I can't believe her last name has left
me for the moment but she's at ucsf I'm
sure you can find her and I can't
remember the answer to your question but
you should oh that's so embarrassing i
gave her last name it will come to me i
hope well i don't know how long you want
to wait for other questions but maybe
I've exhausted you all and if so I
appreciate your paying attention here to
the bitter end I'm and I hope you find
the presentation useful Judy oh listen
to Elizabeth Blackburn thank you so much
done she is the Nobel Prize winner who
won for her work on telomerase thank you
dr. Garber today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing from
November 14 2015 you'll receive an email
from labyrinths alerting me witness
webcast will be available for replay
we'd like you to Ford that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time bye